[Music]
hey time once again for something we
always enjoy here called fan Corrections
[Applause]
okay this is fun it's something we
started a couple of weeks ago it's it's
a segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show now so far many
challengers but no winners alright
tonight a couple of fans named John and
Erin Bates think they caught a mistake
they said it happened during a sketch we
did last week about buying Twitter
insurance hey I'm John and I'm Aaron
Cohn and I work for the Norfolk
Botanical Gardens and we have a bald
eagle cam and I hate to break it to you
on the little boost that you did about
Twitter and shirts when you showed an
eagle fly across the screen and you had
a call that was actually not a bald
eagle call it's or Twitter issue with
the cover your tweets
hey yo ass that was a red tail hawk call
this is the sound of a red-tailed hawk
and this is actually what it bald eagle
sounds like mistake
[Applause]
no sorry John and Aaron but you're the
ones that made the mistake all right
that was a bald eagle that we use it was
a bald eagle call watch the actual
behind-the-scenes footage of how that
sketch God produces okay bald eagle call
take one
whenever you're ready Billy yeah that's
not really what we're looking for do any
impressions maybe like a red-tailed hawk
or something
the challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
report it at team koco.com slash haha I
found an error we'll sort it out here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]